les suisses votent souvent pour élire
leurs représentants locaux et nationaux
pour des mandats de quatre ou cinq ans
et aussi pour donner leur avis lors des
référendums quatre fois par an les
thèmes l'abolition de l'armée les
subventions pour les vaches à cornes la
fiscalité des entreprises sujets
techniques ou de société les suisses
aiment être consultés nous ont su ce
diptyque à une nouvelle optique arrive
avant que l'imposant demande d'une
votation
ils ont sombré corps ou pas ça se passe
très bien là on en a beaucoup et puis la
plupart du temps c'est la droite qui
passe donc c'est pas très équilibré
après au niveau des résultats et vous
participez à tous les coups alors depuis
qu'elle est relation en ligne oui le
référendum un outil plébiscité aussi par
les partis politiques
ainsi ils occupent largement l'espace
médiatique au risque du populisme
depuis une vingtaine d'années c'est
incontestable que l'union démocratique
du centre une formation d'îlots de
droite souverainiste que l'on qualifie
parfois de populiste a pu bien sûr
s'appuyer sur ces instruments pour
porter dans l'espace public un certain
nombre de thématiques qui lui sont
chères en particulier celles qui
concernent les questions migratoires ça
amène vraiment un réquilibrage une
correction à des lois et en parlement
qui parfois me rétro dans un sens ou
dans l'autre
et oui ça peut servir le populisme mais
c'est un dommage collatéral je pense
qu'il faut pouvoir supporter et qu'on
supporte encore en suisse lors d'un
référendum les suisses ont voté pour la
limitation du nombre de travailleurs
étrangers en contradiction avec les
accords de libre échange que leurs pays
avaient déjà signé avec la communauté
européenne
on a sans aucun doute été mauvais en son
temps pour donner les réponses à notre
population est aujourd'hui en dhr se
trouve devant un dilemme c'est à nos
accords bilatéraux qui sont mis en cause
par l'europe parce que
le libre échange est un point
fondamental imposées par l'europe
et oui quelquefois le législateur a bien
du mal d'appliquer la décision du peuple
dossier toujours en suspens un
référendum peut aussi faire bouger les
choses avant le vote
exemple en mars dernier grande question
sur la redevance audiovisuelle et le
service public de télé et de radio
finalement la rts en sort confortée à
plus de 70%
on s'est rendu compte que la population
voulait un service public différent il
ya un certain nombre aussi d'économie
qui ont été annoncées donc même s'il ya
eu un résultat très clair à 70% il ya
quand même des mesures qui ont été
prises
puisqu'il y avait une initiative donc à
même préoccupation d'une partie des
populations
depuis son instauration en 1848 on
compte 600 référendum en suisse aux pays
du consensus politique et de la
proportionnelle la votation apparaît
comme un exemple de démocratie directe
mais ce modèle est il applicable en
france